okay we just got the Tully Clips go in
front of us the mayor of Kiev um he's
going to tell us um how what impact this
is happening on the residence of Key Van
Ukraine these constant now daily attacks
being woken at 3am in the morning we
have we have uh weeks long uh every day
the Russian Center came against the
Drone and missiles to our hometown and a
lot of people killed a lot of buildings
destroyed we have
a big part of people who have an injury
and uh yes of course people people were
angry people very angry it's not the war
it's genocide against Ukraine against
Ukrainian people from Russia today we
saw a child killed two women killed
there's a lot of anger amongst the
residents here about the shelter being
shut they couldn't get down to the
shelter which is near a children's
clinic there's still bodies lying out
there of a child
people go to the shelter and the
explosion was a lot of children
destroyed destroyed kindergarten and
three schools and
the the explosion was after four minutes
when people listen the alarm
and right now we have an investigation
and I'm hoping very soon very soon we
received a clear answer but it's our
main priority safety right now main
priority for everyone in our hometown
and we do it everything was impossible
to save people for people's lives the
French president has said maybe there
could be an end to the war if there was
a negotiation with Vladimir Putin that
maybe he suggested maybe he would be
exonerated from war crimes if he
negotiated what do you think of that
tactic uh which negotiation it's the
Russian we receive a lot of uh
information from Russia let's find
Solutions let's find negotiation let's
finally compromise is I guess it's not
it's not a compromise to give up to
Russian a big part of our country it's
not compromised there I'm more than sure
we're ready to sit in the round table
and talking about a few of Ukraine with
one issues a last Russian soldier left
Ukraine we're ready to sit and finally
compromise right now it's not right time
we defend our homes we defend our
families and our children okay the key
Russian leaders like former president
Dmitry Medvedev have issued very serious
threats against British officials
because they call Britain a leading uh
exponent of this war and they're saying
British officials could be key
legitimate military targets what do you
make of that threat yes of course as the
Russians were upset because Ukraine
received a lot of support and we wish
life important for us thank you for and
the missile system what we receive in
our hometown they actually took tonight
we have 10 ballistic records and
everyone shut down and the last days
more than 20 chemicals wrong every day
okay and measles flying directional
Hometown it's a new modern anti-missile
system shutdown Russians yes of course
accept that upset with the support of
Ukraine and I want to say for British
people for British politicians thank you
very much for support because we're
fighting not just for our homeland we
fighting for democracy for human rights
Russia doesn't have that what do you
make of those threats though because
that is likely to Rattle not just
British officials but European
politicians if they're being he's
basically put a Target on their backs
now wherever they are listen the
everyone's a new friend is a target from
Russians everyone who not agree with
Russian is enemy from Russia and that's
why the Russians
Russian politics terrorist politics you
see do you see impact is the war it's a
special operation against
already killed civilians
foreign
this is the scene where the
investigators are that is the Children's
Clinic that you can see there's still
bodies of a young child nine-year-old
girl and a woman lying outside and
there's a lot of Anger from everyone
here at the residence here because that
shelter was shut the shelter is below
the Children's Clinic a lot of anger
about why that was shut and a feeling
that perhaps the security services are
being complacent naturally those
feelings are going to be extremely
aroused in in the face of death and yet
more fear and anxiety on the streets of
the capital of Ukraine